He's been a fixture of every single big-screen
Batman franchise, but the cinematic attempts
at the Joker have never really lined up with
the version that we see in the comics.
Even when they're great performances with
iconic visuals, there's always something that
the movies get wrong.
We've all seen Thomas and Martha Wayne get
shot down in an alley about 47 times, so we
all know that superhero movies love to give
their viewers an origin story.
It's not just for the good guys, either — almost
every villain who steps onto the screen brings
a whole backstory with them.
Normally, that's not a problem, and can actually
give those villains the pathos that makes
for a compelling story.
In the Joker's case, however, it's the exact
opposite.
The biggest offender in this regard is, of
course, Tim Burton's 1989 Batman film, in
which Jack Nicholson took on the role of the
Clown Prince of Crime.
Not only do we get a full origin story, his
past gets tied back into Batman's own origin
so that we can wrap everything up in a nice
bow, which ultimately makes him less interesting.
We see that he's a weird, catchphrase-spewing
homicidal maniac long before he tumbles into
a vat of acid.
The only real difference, aside from an admittedly
iconic look, is that he gets slightly more
artistic with his murders.
For a while, it seemed like the movies had
learned their lesson on this front.
The Joker that we saw in The Dark Knight shows
up fully formed and even offers conflicting
versions of his own origin depending on who
he's talking to.
"You want to know how I got these scars?"
Eve more recently, Jared Leto's version in
Suicide Squad is downright inexplicable in
pretty much every way.
Now, though, we have an entire movie about
the Joker's origin, without any signs of Batman,
set for release this year.
Hopefully this time, they'll finally be able
to get rid of all that compelling mystery
he's been burdened with for so long!
Fans have long accepted the idea that it's
Batman who's Bruce Wayne's true identity,
and not the billionaire playboy alter-ego,
and it's a good rule of thumb.
And yet, the movies treat the Joker, someone
who exists specifically in response to Batman,
as someone who always has to have that personal
connection.
Admittedly, they do this with most of the
villains as a little bit of origin story shorthand.
In the Joel Schumacher films, the Riddler
and Poison Ivy are both former employees of
Wayne Industries, out for revenge against
their old boss.
The Joker, however, exists specifically to
be a counterpoint to Batman.
The person under the mask is basically irrelevant
compared to the ideological battle being waged
against the symbol.
That aspect of the Joker's character, however,
is continually missed by the films.
In the '89 Batman, it's not enough that the
Joker's trying to murder the entire city with
a cloud of poison gas, there has to be a personal
connection to get the crimefighter into action.
Even in 2019's Joker solo film, billed as
being more of a character study than a superhero
flick, Thomas Wayne appears as an antagonist
to provide that connection yet again.
For all its flaws, the '89 Batman movie incorporates
one longtime, definitive element of the Joker
that no other film does.
It's the one that remembers his trademark
is poison.
"With a new secret ingredient, smiley."
… "What is that?"
In the comics, Joker Toxin dates back to the
character's very first appearance in 1940,
and has been a signature of the character
ever since.
In addition to the outright creepiness of
a corpse with a smile frozen on its face,
there's nothing that captures the Joker's
mission statement quite as well as leaving
behind dead bodies in his own image, creating
a world with more Jokers.
For obvious reasons, the campy, kid-friendly
1966 Batman film didn't involve a lot of poison
murders.
When Heath Ledger offered up a performance
that defined the Joker for a new generation,
his weapons of choice were knives, explosives,
and complicated moral dilemmas, which left
very few people smiling.
The Suicide Squad Joker seems to favor guns
and knives as well, which we know from the
scene where he's laying on the floor in a
weird circle of them that also includes baby
clothes, champagne bottles, and a laptop.
It's definitely a striking visual in its own
right, but it gets a little less sinister
once you start imagining Jared Leto spending
hours arranging it all to get it just right.
One one level, you have to hand it to the
cinematic versions of the Joker: they always
set their sights pretty big.
In Batman '89, the Joker attempts to poison
the entirety of Gotham during the city's bicentennial,
using a deadly parade.
"My balloons.
Those are my balloons."
In The Dark Knight, he tries to trick a literal
boatload of citizens into blowing themselves
up, and that's after a series of high-profile
murders and the bombing of a hospital.
The Joker of Suicide Squad doesn't get much
screen time, but it's already established
in Batman v Superman that he killed Robin.
Even in the '60s version, the Joker's part
of a plot to vaporize every delegate to the
United Nations, at the height of the Cold
War!
Of course, this isn't really a departure from
the source material.
Since the '80s, the Joker's body count has
been ramped up to the extreme, resulting in
a character who's only slightly less lethal
than, say, the bubonic plague.
Even his attempt to take out the UN is something
that would eventually make its way into the
comics as part of the "A Death in the Family"
story, even if it's always overshadowed by
Robin being killed.
The thing is, that's not the only thing the
Joker does.
While he has a long history of wild, theatrical
murders, the Joker is also known for his unpredictability.
Sometimes he shows up and poisons everyone,
and sometimes he applies for a patent on smiling
fish and only turns to murder once he's denied.
Sometimes he tries to become the first criminal
to commit crimes on the moon.
A lot of those stories might result from his
decades operating under the Comics Code, but
that bizarre unpredictability is what makes
the Joker work as more than just a slasher
movie bad guy.
The Joker wasn't the first over-the-top, thematic
crook to show up on the comics page, but if
you're looking for a place to draw the line
between "villain" and "supervillain," he makes
a good place to start.
"...Wait'll they get a load of me.”
His arrival in Batman #1 set the standard
for costumed criminals, and provided the blueprint
that supervillains are still using almost
80 years later.
More often than not, though, movies treat
the Joker as just a slightly more colorful
representative of traditional organized crime.
While that was true for his first few appearances,
Joker became far more than that.
In Batman '89, the Joker eventually winds
up in full-on supervillain mode — complete
with an army of henchmen in matching satin
jackets — but at heart, Jack Napier is a
gangster, and his first actions after his
transformation involve taking over the mob.
The same goes for The Dark Knight, where the
Joker's introduction involves him taking a
contract for the murder of Batman, eventually
destabilizing the city's organized crime in
order to sow chaos.
"What do you propose."
"Well we kill the Batman.”
Suicide Squad might actually be the film that
goes furthest, showing the Joker as a mob
boss, holding court in a nightclub that caters
to facial tattoo enthusiasts.
Presumably, this is meant to tie the Joker
to a more realistic idea of crime, which seems
pretty unnecessary.
Are audiences only going to accept a genocidal
maniac who was turned into a clown by falling
into a pit of chemicals, who also fights a
man dressed up as a human-sized bat, only
if we can relate him to The Sopranos?
This is a weird thing to say about the Joker,
but sometimes, less is more.
Since his first live-action appearance in
1966, the design for the Joker in live action
has become more and more over the top.
From a visual standpoint, Jack Nicholson was
a more-or-less accurate re-creation of what
we'd seen in the comics.
Heath Ledger combined the traditional purple
suit with weird, studiously sloppy face-paint
and his infamous scars.
And Jared Leto… well, you know.
The guy has "damaged" tattooed on his forehead,
and that is an aesthetic that doesn't even
exist in the same universe as the concept
of subtlety.
While that particular take on the Joker is
certainly memorable, it's not nearly as effective
as the relatively restrained Dark Knight version,
and not even close to being as iconic as the
simpler Batman '89 style.
When there's too much to focus on from a visual
standpoint, that visual loses its meaning
and just becomes a jumbled mess.
2019's Joker seems to be heading back in a
slightly more restrained direction.
Joaquin Phoenix is back to the painted-on
clown makeup, but with the colorful purple
suit that matches his comic book counterpart's
established tradition pretty well.
From a structural standpoint, one of the biggest
problems with the movie versions of the Joker
is more of a problem with movies themselves:
they only really use him once.
While he's certainly great as a one-shot villain,
the Joker is used best when he's a persistent
threat.
The idea that he's always out there, able
to just stroll out of Arkham Asylum and begin
his next chaotic crime spree, is a really
cool part of his character, just like it is
for any comic book supervillain.
You never know who's going to make their shocking
return, or which mastermind might be manipulating
things from behind the scenes in order to
make the hero's life a nightmare.
That's when the Joker works best — when
his exit from the story is more ambiguous
than definitive, when no one finds the body,
and when you know he'll be back for another
round.
"I think you and I are destined to do this
forever."
Unfortunately, with the very recent exception
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe, movies are
meant to be more self-contained.
Having the Joker linger in the background
while a movie focused on less popular and
marketable villains would make about as much
sense as having Darkseid cooling his heels
offscreen while a C-list bad guy like Steppenwolf
fought the Justice League in their first big-screen
outing.
Interestingly enough, there was a thought
of doing this during the Dark Knight trilogy;
the Joker survives the events of the film,
and the novelization for The Dark Knight Rises
even mentions that he is the last remaining
inmate of Arkham Asylum.
Unfortunately, Heath Ledger's tragic real-life
death prevented any of those plans from coming
to fruition, leaving his performance as a
singular take on the Joker.
The Joker's scary.
He has to be, right?
He's the ultimate creepy clown, a mass murderer
plotting death behind his smile, an unpredictable
foil for a hero determined to stop him at
almost any cost.
In all honesty, the movies have that one down
— the scene in Batman '89 where the Joker
unwraps his face and then shatters a mirror,
laughing while a stammering doctor tries to
blame his work on a tray full of rusty tools?
That's still legitimately unsettling, and
a high point of the film.
That said, there's one other thing the Joker
ought to be: funny.
It really shouldn't be that difficult to pull
off, since horror and comedy both rely on
a punch of surprise to get their reaction,
but it's been a tricky balance for the movies
to walk.
The closest we've seen to nailing it is, once
again, Ledger's performance in The Dark Knight.
"... hi."
Ledger's Joker pulls off great, genuinely
funny bits of comedy in his performance without
ever losing that undercurrent of menace.
It's a necessary element, recasting Batman
as the straight man in an unintentional comedy
partnership that usually ends with someone
dead.
As for the others, well, Nicholson's version
wound up being more weird than funny, and
Leto's… well, that performance was hilarious,
but probably not in a way that was intentional.
Still, has to count for something, right?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
heroes and villains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.